Great job on creating your hello server.
Now that we have a working web server,
let's see if we can add some
CRUD operations to our site.
This will be a fun activity, where
you'll finally bring together all of
the major aspects you've learned
about creating data-driven websites.
In this next section, you are going
to modify our web server code,
such that we can create,
read, update, and
delete restaurants from our
restaurant menu database.
I will be adding these features
in the next five sections,
divided up into objectives.
I highly encourage you to read through
the objective's descriptions that I'll
be presenting in a moment, and
attempt to solve them before
seeing the solution videos.
Up until now,
we've been moving pretty quickly.
But this is an opportunity to slow down,
and
get messy,
figuring out these challenges.
I'll be sharing my answers with you,
but through this process you
might even create more elegant
solutions than my own.
Before we get started coding,
let me list off the objectives I
want to complete for this project.
Listing objectives helps me to
understand the scope of my project and
create identifiable
milestones along the way.
These objectives should also serve
as guidelines you should follow to
complete this project.
The goal of objective one is to
modify the webserver.py file,
so that opening local hosts or
8080/restaurants,
the user sees a list of all
the restaurant names in the database.
To complete objective two,
after the name of each restaurant,
there should be a link to edit and
delete each restaurant.
These links don't have to work for now.
They should just be visible.
The third objective goal is to add
code such that there is a page to
create new restaurants, with a form for
writing the new restaurant name.
The form should create a post request
that creates a new restaurant menu item
in the database.
To complete objective four, we enhance
the web server such that users can
rename a restaurant and persist
this edit to the database via post.
And the last objective
creates a feature,
such that by clicking Delete,
takes the user to a confirmation page.
That then sends a post command to
the database to delete
the selected restaurant.
If you don't get it on the first attempt
or have to spend some time debugging or
looking things up online, that's okay.
Even the best of programmers
have to debug code.
Try to spend about three hours working
on each of the objectives before viewing
the solutions if you're still
relatively new to programming.
Don't forget to use your resources
like the Python documentation, and
tools like the source code inspector in
Chrome to help you debug your program,
and don't hesitate to ask
questions in the forum.
I'll be going over the solution
to this challenge piece by piece,
solving each objective in order,
once you're finished with an object,
continue to the next video to see
my implementation of the solution.